hello everyone
i welcome you all to simply learn
jambo is a popular framework nowadays
and you must have heard it
almost every websites and web
applications uses django in some way or
other for their web development
so in today's session we'll discuss what
is django framework
let's start by discussing what is a web
framework
a web framework is a software framework
that is created to support the
development of dynamic sites web
services and web applications
it supports creation development and
publishing of the web applications and
websites
it can include web services apis and
other resources
some of the features why web framework
are so popular
they are easy to maintain
they have high scalability
and they are compatible with almost
every browser
and it is very easy to learn
now that we know what is the web
framework let's move on to discuss what
is django
a django is an open source framework
that is used for backend web
applications based on python
it is based on mvt web framework
and its primary goal is to ease the
creation of complex data driven websites
it can handle higher amount of traffic
and transactions
now let's discuss why django is so
popular
first it has a very vast and excellent
community
django has been in the market for the
past 13 years which means it has been
used by millions of users and improved
by thousands of developers
it is super easy to find a community of
developers who know in and out of django
and have experience coding with it
the second feature is it is an open
source software
django is introduced to the market with
documentation far above the usual
standards of the open source
technologies it has improved over time
and it is considered to be the best
example of the open source documentation
in the world
the third feature is it has enhanced
security django is super secure
it has covered all the loopholes by
default which are once left open for the
backend developers to compete although
by using django you may not feel those
loopholes but the expert backend
developers can tell the quantity and
security of work done by django
the fourth feature is rapid development
django is a framework that takes less
time to build web applications while
working with django you don't have to
start from the scratch you only need the
basic knowledge of the backend because
most of the work django handles itself
the last feature is it is very versatile
the versatility of that application
signifies its ability to perform well in
different domains january spread its
hand on various domains out there in the
market
now it's time to see the companies using
django
some of the major companies are the
washington post instagram
pinterest netflix firefox and many more
now we'll discuss the model view
template on which the django
architecture is built
the first one is model
a model provides the interface for the
data stored in the database
it is responsible for maintaining the
data and handling the logical structure
for the entire web application
a view is the user interface of the web
applications
it is responsive for displaying model
data to the user and also to take up
information from the user
and the last one is template
just like viewing mvc django uses
template in its framework
templates are a sponsor for the entire
user interface it handles all the static
parts of the webpage along with the html
which the user's visiting web page will
receive
so with this we come to an end to this
tutorial i hope the video was useful for
you if yes do share and subscribe to our
channel until then thank you again and
happy learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here